it's great to welcome to the program
today back to the program I should say
dr. John Gartner founder of duty to warn
co-editor of Rocketman nuclear madness
and the mind of Donald Trump he taught
in the Department of Psychiatry at Johns
Hopkins Medical Center for 28 years John
great to have you back on today great to
be back
I really enjoyed an show so listen I
don't even know where to start because
since you were last on you know you
you've been tracking what is a
concerning behavior by the President of
the United States from a mental health
perspective we had this unexpected visit
to Walter Reed Hospital in November we
don't have any particular reason to
think that it was mental health or
cognitive related specifically but we
don't really have a very clear answer as
to why did go the idea that it was
getting a jump on next year's physical
is hard to believe at best what what are
you seeing over the last few months how
much have you been looking at this
walter reed thing well actually go to
the walter reed thing i have a theory
about this based on no facts good
although apparently it was reported that
he had reported some kind of chest pains
that had been reported i don't know if
they've been verified i saw that it was
speculated and denied by the white house
but their denials don't mean very much
don't mean anything right what they deny
they confirm in most cases but actually
given his fast food diet and as being
overweight and as being high on the
cholesterol that's not surprising but
actually realize this the chest pains is
one of the most common presentations at
an emergency room and 90% of the time
it's a panic attack right so all this
started when the impeachment stuff
started heating up so my theory based
again today on speculation is he may
have experienced chest pains as his
presenting problem but really he was
having a panic attack
actually if he was having a panic attack
that might be the most reality centered
thing that he's done well that's what I
actually I actually speculated that it
may have been one of those situations
where you feel like you're having a
heart attack and they do tests and the
doctor comes out and says you didn't
have a heart attack
I think that this was a panic attack the
what makes me skeptical about that is it
seems that Trump lacks
the personality traits that would get
him to actually panic because that
requires sort of some self-awareness of
the situation you're in yeah yeah no I
think it's a very good point in fact
part of his personality disorder is a
lack of anxiety over being caught or
punished or that these Psychopaths don't
seem to weigh the probable risks and
consequences of their behavior you know
all these people in jail like you know
what do they think they were how do they
think they were even going to get away
with it you know but somehow they
thought they were so I agree with you
about that but the walls are really
closing in on him and this is one of the
reasons actually that we should be very
very concerned right now I mean that we
predicted this actually a couple of
years ago and even more strongly a year
ago that this day of reckoning would
come that someday he would be held
accountable we thought it was gonna be
for the Muller investigation it was we
didn't know that the Ukraine situation
was even going to emerge we couldn't see
that in our crystal ball but that once
the ass hit the fan I don't know what
you can say words we can say on your
platform that that he was going to
decompensate and that he would become
even more dangerous because first of all
the situation is his cognitive decline
has continued he now however has created
a situation where there are no safety on
the gun there are no adults in the White
House anymore and this is what these
dictators do they purge the government
and the bureaucracy of anyone who isn't
slavishly loyal and and cinco phonic so
not only in his administration but their
find out today that they he's fired a
third of the diplomats you know I mean
he's getting rid of anyone not only the
ones in Ukraine that he tried to get rid
of but anyone who could possibly stand
in his way or say no or offer a
conflicting opinion or provide expertise
or information which contradicts his
crazy conspiracy theories all those
people have been removed and now he's in
a state of maximum agitation as we said
in our last op-ed in USA Today we think
he may be even having a bit of a
hypomanic episode and that would kind of
fit with the chest pain thing meaning
his whole energy level this is is now at
a frantic pace
and if you look at his activities
they're becoming even more erratic look
I think most recently very dramatically
was his withdrawal from Syria where he
literally had a conversation with the
head of Turkey president of Turkey and
then picked up the phone and told the
troops to start withdrawing without
discussing it he didn't even discuss it
with one member of his own
administration no something like that
could that just be that he's ignorant
and doesn't care what anyone else thinks
but not necessarily indicative of a
cognitive concern well I think here that
it's really the psychiatric appoint I
was making here is that there's
something impulsive and accelerated so
there's something manic about his
decision-making now and actually if you
read the descriptions of his tweets is
when the impeachment think just very
heating up people were commenting on the
tweets being manic that was one of the
words people kept using to describe them
he was like tweeting like 30 40 50 times
a day you know with this sort of screed
that was completely off the hook but in
other words that's not an abnormal for
him but now he was doing it more and
more quickly and more rapidly and more
free and more frequently so that there's
kind of a way in which the water is
boiling now the boiling point has kind
of its boiling over so in terms of the
so some of the policy stuff can be sort
of a proxy to his cognitive state but
last time we talked we had all of these
examples of the slurring which we don't
know if may be related to sort of some
kind of drug abuse or cognitive decline
there was him repeating that he wants to
find the oranges of an investigation he
repeated it twice and you could see that
his he seemed to have some recognition
that he was saying something that didn't
make sense but sort of unable to correct
it
we had him getting off of Air Force One
and wandering away from his car and
having to be brought back something
similar happened in Argentina when he
wandered offstage after being introduced
and shaking hands with the president are
we seeing more of those things or are we
mostly looking at sort of through policy
as a proxy no actually an
honor of your show I I made a little
sheet of the latest science of cognitive
decline first of all I just want to
point out this excellent book from
anonymous summarizes it very well when
they say he stumbles he slurs he gets
confused he can't synthesize information
he can't remember anything and this
doesn't just happen sometimes so that's
a summary but most recently in the past
few months for example when he was
speaking to the troops this is just a
month ago
he said our armed forces have always
lived by the words of Douglas MacArthur
you notice in both those cases he didn't
finish the word this is really a
phonetic para faiza that we really only
see and people who are either drunk or
developing Alzheimers but no there's an
organic brain problem either temporary
or permanent in this case it's not
temporary so it can't be that you drunk
okay so let's look at that's actually
very interesting so this is a symptom
which you as a mental health
professional can say we there is a
limited number of explanations for that
particular symptom and for example the
alleged dyslexia that some suspect Trump
has that would not be an possible
explanation for that linguistic
phenomena no because people who I don't
miss because examples instead of stock
market he said sock rocket he couldn't
pronounce obsolete or applicable
he said the NATO just this week the US
has the most powerful powerful military
in the word he once a powerful yeah he
said power role he couldn't finish the
word so this kind of yes so to get to
your point they we have a term in
psychiatry that something could be
passed a pneumonic meaning if someone
has that symptom we know what the
illness is as you say a limited number
of possibilities there's a very limited
impossibilities for this kind of
breakdown and the ability to speak
English and it's not just pronunciation
it's also comprehension so he's showing
a loss in his ability to comprehend in
the complexity of his sentences and his
ability to stay on topic without going
off on relevancy on his repetitions
repetition is actually a sign of
cognitive decline
you keep saying same thing over and over
again his use of superlatives
everything's the greatest or the worst
or there's no nuance in the words and
also his memory remember he said his
father was born in Germany when it was
his grandfather that was born in Germany
well he recently said to the president
of Italy who we call president
mozzarella instead of mozzarella okay
and said we've been allies since ancient
Rome I mean he's getting time to America
didn't exist
America was build the Native Americans
during this age in Rome
so in others he's getting all these
times confused and places confused and
names confused it's it's it's more of a
generic breakdown even his even his
balance is poor there's a generic ink
with Alzheimer's there's a breakdown in
all of the cognitive functions so that
actually you mentioned the so let me
bring up one other element related to
the Walter Reed visit let's let's
imagine that we just don't know what the
Walter Reed visit was about one of the
things that was observed afterwards was
that he was getting off of Air Force One
from the low stairs rather than the high
stairs and that at least one time when
getting off of the high stairs he had a
senator walking right next to him really
kind of keeping him up against the
railing yeah again Rock propping him up
was the sort of colloquial way that it
was described does that tell us anything
in terms of how it might connect with
what you're discussing yes loss of
balance goes with it because again all
of the mental functions are
deteriorating including the ability to
maneuver physically in space you know so
his is stumbling verbally and a
stumbling physically are part of the
same generic overall deterioration what
would be the test that would determine
whether something is going on here well
we've been calling for two years now for
him to get a neuropsychological battery
of tests it's a it's a battery of tests
that evaluate people at a psycho their
their cognitive functioning at a whole
bunch of levels with a whole bunch of
different tasks you know what we
actually
asked Rodney Randy Jackson his doctor in
a letter with 70 doctors asking him to
give him lamoco which he did but and he
passed the MOCA which he said proved he
was a stable genius and more intelligent
than all past presidents which is a
little bit like saying you know I passed
a first grade exam and that makes me
Mensa you know it's most kindergarteners
just Eve you said can pass the mocha
it's things like can you identify a
camel can you repeat three words
backwards yeah but are they the smart
kindergarteners know the ones who
couldn't do it we would hold them back
right so it's true he hadn't reached
that level of dementia but you know one
of the people in the anonymous book said
the Trump is sort of like going to the
White House is kind of like going to a
nursing home and your uncle is running
around the courtyard without pants I
mean that was in other words he's not at
the point where he's so demented that he
can't remember though name or won't
recognize his own children but he thinks
his father was born in Germany and he
can't pronounce words and he doesn't
remember things he can't understand
thing so he's given this a guy he used
to go to Ivy League schools even if his
dad got him and he still went there and
now he's really fallen so far from his
own baseline and that's one of the
things that we use to determine
cognitive decline is different people
have different abilities right but we
have to compare someone to their own
baseline you look at speech as he made
in the eighties he sounds extremely
articulate and bright even though he
says like a jerk and you compare him to
now and you see that he's like lost like
30 or 40 IQ points what did you make I
don't know if you saw this but in during
the first impeachment hearings he went
out and did one of the helicopter press
conference where he had notes about what
he reportedly told Gordon Sunland during
a phone call and he seemed very erratic
yelling I want nothing no quit you know
that very strange kind of kind of like
strained and repeating over and over
again
was there anything about that episode
that either coincides with or goes
against the impression that you're
getting from his other behavior well
first of all the fact that he has to
have carried notes right written in
sharpie to say no quid pro quo
it's almost like the mocha that's
forwards forward he can't remember
forwards without having to refer to
notes so I think that's already telling
you something about his cognitive level
of functioning and the other thing I
just want to say is he just sings this
is bizarre stuff you know like he was
saying yesterday that you know the next
president
they'll impeach him if he goes to the
refrigerator and gets oranges Robert
isn't that just isn't some of this just
Trump's personality you know that's
where it's really constructive to look
at the videos of him in the 80s cuz
really he was literally the same jerk
then that he is now because a
personality disorder is a lifetime
disorder you could have it from the time
you're young and you have it till you
die and in this case it's actually
gotten worse we've talked about this in
narcissism the malignant narcissists
gain power their grandiosity and their
paranoia as well as their sadism in
their ante so becomes inflamed because
now they feel empowered like he says now
I'm president I can do whatever I want
you know and so he his personality
disorder actually has gotten worse but
his cognitive functioning is much worse
than it was when he was still a jerk as
a young man so we really have now a
series of forces that are making him
maximally dangerous right now you know
we were all kind of getting a laugh out
of how the world leaders were laughing
at him at NATO and me laughing at him
but remember because Barack Obama
laughing at him that you know goaded him
to run for president this is a guy who
gets even okay so now he wants to get
even with these guys at NATO our allies
you know and he's already been
antagonistic but I'm saying he feels
like he's on his back he feels weakened
he feels attacked and so his response is
to do something more aggressive more
destructive to feel more powerful and so
all of the things that are making him a
wounded animal are making him more
dangerous now than he ever was we've
been speaking with dr. John Gartner
founder of duty to warn co-editor of
Rocketman nuclear madness and the mind
of Donald Trump he taught in the
Department of Psychiatry at Johns
Hopkins
medical center for nearly 30 years
always so great to have you on yeah
thank you it was good to be on
appreciated